so imagine an inner circle in hell where
you are doomed to defend the biggest
screwup of your life that's where you'll
find Hillary I won the places that
represent two-thirds of America's gross
domestic product so I won the places
that our optimistic diverse dynamic
moving forward and his whole campaign
make America great again was looking
backwards you know you didn't like black
people getting rights you don't like
women you know getting jobs you don't
want it you know see that Indian
Americans succeeding more than you are
whatever your problem is I'm gonna solve
it hmm beautiful so there she is again
pointing out the places where she won
imagine a quarterback who just lost a
Super Bowl pointing out that he threw no
interceptions that doesn't matter that's
not how we keep score you also threw no
touchdowns that's Hillary but also not
in this clip she blamed white women who
voted for Trump on a fear of disobeying
their husbands or brothers or sons how
profoundly sexist is that women are too
weak to make up their own minds I guess
she'd know given her own weak
subservience to her deceitful husband
but that's not the worst part
that's what she worked in that
indian-american aside because you know
she's in India talking to Indian people
that's how her mind works oh look
Indians I'll say Trump voters hate
Indians - and so sheep and are using her
default mechanism divisive identity
politics she still lives in a world
where you don't see actual people just
the group they belong to and so she
looked at the audience and only saw them
I wonder what they saw looking back a
sore loser
that could be why she lost she's so
bitter you could make an old fashioned
out of her tears all right why don't you
just want her to go away it's not a good
look for your party I think she's doing
great she's saying like she was telling
the truth and what as obvious to
everyone india telling that half of
america sucks that's wonderful no I
don't know the racists are eating was
that guess what immigration and
immigrants huge issue that benefited
Donald Trump in the last election and
women who voted for Trump
just like know what we said was that
once the Comey thing came out ten days
before that all the pressure coming from
Republican white men the biggest Trump
supporters of all on their wives and
girlfriends are evil all of them say oh
look you know you can't believers you're
gonna up in jail look at her it's
corrupt I don't think there's anything
wrong here I think though for you
Greg Gutfeld is a minute mr. sycophant
of the Trump world I will say this cycle
you own a pair of psychopaths Bunch Bob
and Greg I would say that you know you
need her do you want her you don't want
her I want her to go away know what she
wrote but you just probably want to say
that you want to go but you love her
imagines you without that's Nancy Pelosi
how about you in love as our man so how
about you without it is Warren oh yeah
they are they are in this universe it's
not like I'm asking them to visit us
this is all over the news you can say I
want it but it does fill a segment but I
don't want it I think I would like a job
without her I think I think you might be
yeah I mean Hillary doesn't like people
bottom line that's what it isn't like
half the country we know she called half
of them deplorable but she lost because
she was a deplorable candidate she
doesn't like women too much doesn't
think much of women to assume that women
just will vote for someone because of
their gender is to really not understand
women women vote for whoever candidate
they think is going to be the best
president the United States and how do
you know one or Hillary whoever what was
going on in the living room after the
Comey announcement you know for a fact
that husbands were telling their wives
don't vote for Hillary see and check the
polls you would be like wow I really
listen I I think it's kind of like with
you of President champa you enjoy him so
much oh really I might regain my sanity
no I just wish that Hillary Clinton was
a little bit more positive
that she embraced everybody in this
country and wasn't constantly demonizing
and also blaming everyone else for the
loss of the election besides herself so
those are like some familiar themes and
I think people get tired of hearing this
kind of akin like bitter tone yeah Dana
you know what happened before she got up
and looked around at the audience
Indian people let me work this into the
speech how to do it well and I think
that it does prevent Democrats from
accusing Republicans of only focusing on
Hillary if she is out there making
comments like this she can have a post
political career and gives big speeches
that were maybe be inspirational but
yeah well I lost but you know what I
tried and they there are ways to do that
there are stories out there about her
wanting to play a role in 2018 I have a
feeling her dance card is gonna be kind
of in wait speaking of dancing are we
gonna show her tiptoeing down the stairs
you're not gonna show the video
I don't think so maybe that'll be my one
more thing there you go